what's up fellas Mark cockerbeard here
master of Jiu Jitsu back for another
video today we are going to be
summarizing up replication in hopefully
10 minutes or less so I can make a nice
little title and click bait you guys so
let's go ahead and get into it because I
am wasting time already the iPad is out
I'm ready to go someone in my comments
recently asked me if I could make this
video and guess what I was already
planning on doing it anyway so I asked
them if they wanted to make out still
haven't heard back yet let's see how
that goes for me so anyways let's
conclude replication what is the point
of replication well if we go here over
to the draw Tab and I get out my little
marker the point is now that instead of
having one database we have a bunch of
them right we are no longer just reading
or writing to necessarily one place but
we could be potentially reading from
many places we could potentially be
writing too many places so what does
this afford US firstly and most
importantly it affords us durability if
I go ahead and nuke this data center
right here we've still gotten many other
databases left to read from and write to
so of course we also have throughput
instead of just having to write to one
place if I have many clients who are all
writing to the same database node guess
what the next thing they can do is start
writing to different database nodes and
what that means
is that you've spread out the throughput
you can effectively make your whole
system faster and perform more rights
without giving users a hard time and
lastly of course this is really good if
you have a geography of many users you
know we've got some Indian guys some
Australian guys and they can all write
to their own special Data Center and so
of course that is going to speed things
up as well so let's move on to some
types of single leader replication that
we covered the pros and cons of them and
then we're going to conclude this thing
so first off we have single leader
replication so the point is here that of
course we've got a master and the rest
of them are going to be followers slaves
whatever you want to call it this guy
could also be a leader because it's
2023.
um so the point is All rights go to that
master all reads can come from any of
the nodes and typically this will be
eventually consistent if it isn't
eventually consistent it means that
pretty much you're writing to all of the
nodes at the same time before a write
technically goes through and that will
take forever so it's very impractical
this is probably eventually consistent
so what are the pros and cons of this
type of setup well the biggest Pro of
course is that there's no red conflicts
because you're only writing to one
single leader on the other hand when you
only write to one leader it means that
you now have a single point of failure
in your system AKA The Leader a follower
can go down and you know whatever you
can just set up another follower and and
start sending rights to it but at the
same time if your leader goes down then
you're really in trouble because who do
you write to you can designate one of
the followers to become a leader but now
you're running the risk of something
like split brain where you're writing to
multiple places at the same time there
are certain distributed consensus
mechanisms that do solve this problem
but that is a topic for a subsequent
video and of course in addition to that
by virtue of also having one single
leader we have low right throughput in
general if we're all writing to the same
node it means that all the rights have
to go through one single bottleneck
let's go ahead now and move on to
multi-leader replication so you've got
my beautifully drawn picture over here
of a bunch of nodes in Harmony and
basically the point is they're all
sending rights to and from one another
it's complete chaos the beauty of that
is if I have many people writing they
can write to any single one of these
nodes and they can also read from any
single one of these nodes so what does
that mean it means that we have high
right throughput this is a really really
useful setup if we have many users in
many different Geographic areas because
now we can each write to our own Data
Center
at the same time we also now have to
deal with right conflicts so I made a
whole video devoted to write conflicts
and why they suck and how they're hard
to deal with the point is you can't just
use a timestamp to decide which right
was later because clocks are bad they're
unreliable
and there's clock drift so again they're
not that useful what can you do instead
you could use something like version
vectors
in order to detect whenever we have a
concurrent right and whenever we have a
concurrent right we basically have two
options one option is to store both of
those concurrent rights which is known
as storing siblings
and then eventually some other user can
come along and basically check those out
and say okay here's the one that this
value should actually be and the other
option is to use something like a crdt
where a crdt effectively is the database
merging those rights for you obviously
this doesn't work in every situation but
there are some data structures that you
can easily represent with the crdt like
a counter or a set or things like that
and then of course finally we have the
most cracked of all of these leaderless
replication so in a leaderless
replication instead of just writing to
one node at a time we can write to many
nodes at a time and the main thing to
know about leaderless replication is the
concept of a quorum so in this case I've
got three database nodes so that means
that n is going to be three and now if
every single time that I write to my
setup I'm able to write to two nodes and
every single time that I oh my God what
was I writing there and every single
time that I read from my setup I'm going
to read from two nodes it means that
we're guaranteed to see at least one
node with the most up-to-date right
every single time that we perform a
write and a read right because if I
write two nodes and then I read from two
nodes we're going to have at least one
node in overlap and then this guy over
here can pick the right with the highest
version number
and so by picking the right with the
highest version number for a given key
you know he might see Jordan is a 10 out
of 10 on one with a version number of
you know let's say 26 and then Jordan
might also be from the other node uh six
out of ten
oh I stopped writing for some reason a
six out of 10 with a version number of
25 it means that the one where I'm a 10
out of 10 wins because that's version
number 26. so that is kind of the gist
between leaderless replication and in
the background these things stay
consistent with one another via read
repair which is basically the most up to
database the most up-to-date database
correcting the other databases and then
there's also anti-entropy
in the background and that's basically
the database sending each other their
changes oftentimes through a data
structure like Merkle trees and that's
just a process that happens
asynchronously in the background so what
are the pros and cons of a setup like
this well the main Pros are that we have
relatively high ride throughput why is
that even though we have to write to
many nodes at once which obviously is
going to bottleneck us it would be a lot
quicker if we could just write to one
and say okay we're good
it is the case that we now get to write
to many nodes instead of just one place
and so instead of having one single
bottleneck we can distribute these
rights amongst many nodes and we're in
better shape for doing those so probably
a lower right throughput than something
like a multi-liter replication but a
higher right throughput than single
leader replication at least in theory
and then of course we also have Quorum
reads and writes so that's what I
mentioned which is that we can almost
guarantee the correctness of our system
when we use quorums where basically the
number of nodes that you write to and
read from have to be greater than the
number of total nodes in your system
then on the other hand we also have low
read throughput why is that well for
starters you're now reading from a bunch
of different places so if you have to
read from say five different places
instead of reading from one different
place it's going to take a lot longer to
ensure that you are going to get all of
that data you can read in parallel but
it's likely that one of those nodes
might be a little bit slow and then
that's going to slow things down
Additionally you also still have to deal
with right conflicts it's very very
possible that you know I could be
writing here writing to the same exact
nodes as this first guy and it's the
case that this right is going to win on
the middle node but this right is going
to win on the top node so again right
conflicts still very possible in a
leaderless replication setup and it is
because of things like write conflicts
that Quorum reads and writes are not
perfect right they're very good but
there are still times where they fail
they can also fail due to things like
sloppy quorums which I mentioned the
leaderless replication video and they
can also fail due to basically just
having a right that only partially goes
through but it doesn't hit a quorum
right threshold
okay so that is pretty much going to
conclude this video guys I hope this
summarizes things very concisely
obviously I did Breeze through things on
purpose and part of that is because I
just spent the last like 10 videos
explaining all of them so if there is a
part of this one you don't fully
understand or you say oh he really
breathes through that I highly highly
recommend just going back and watching
the entire video for that replication
schema anyways guys I hope you have a
great weekend I will try and do the same
if the Knicks lose tonight I will not
have a great weekend and uh yeah I'll
take it from there so see you guys in
the next one